and a man may be one step closer to
finding his father who drowned decades
ago thanks for joining us here at six
i'm denise faldiz i'm kirsten joyce the
clark county coroner now narrowing down
the estimated age for a set of remains
found at lake mead the 8 news now
i-team's david charn speaking to a man
who's now more confident those bones
could be his father david yeah this set
of bones discovered in calville bay back
in may it's not the murder victim
founded that barrel but the remains of
somebody who investigators say likely
drowned many years ago as we first told
you just a couple of weeks ago here todd
kolodd believes that person could be his
father daniel kola drowned in the same
area in 1958 there's his photo he was
just 22 and a half years old the
coroner's office today saying those
remains are likely from a person who was
between 23 and 38 when they died while
his father was six months shy of that
cut off todd kolod says this is just the
latest bit of information that points to
his dad he talked to me from overseas
today with each clue i always expect in
my mind that it's going to put put us
farther away from our goal
but consistently
each clue is putting us closer
and this is like a bull's-eye
a bull's-eye he says well the i-team
showed the photos of the remains to a
dentist who said she believes the person
was missing several front teeth and
likely wore a partial denture now that's
important because daniel kolod was in a
car crash a few years before his death
and he wore a partial denture
a spokesperson for the county says the
coroner is attempting to identify these
remains in the other two sets also
discovered at the lake and they're doing
this all through dna and that could take
years though this new piece of
information is providing this family
just a little more hope tonight i'm
david charns live local now